welcome to this video it's a 15 minute
game against max power from Denmark
pretty high rated and in the 15 minute
pool you don't see many players above
2100 okay mm-hmm so what do I play here
yeah that's a 15-minute game I can
invest a moment here to make up my mind
I played the BOGO often obviously
practicing lines from my book project
but what else could I do a kid mm-hmm
maybe try form something more aggressive
him yeah even the bloomenfeld gambit
with b5 is interesting okay I'll give
this a shot it's obviously a bit risky
but trying something new is not not a
bad thing
okay forgotten the exact moves order do
they play a 6-year on d5 first I'll
start with a six not sure if this is
right actually but hopefully it's not
not a mistake I know that D five and a
six is usually combined here I'm
thinking of it maybe in the first T 5 is
better really yeah okay
let's let's continue I was briefly
thinking mm II can play III Bishop b5
things like that could be a problem
hmm interesting what's normal normal set
up here on is with g3 not sure though if
a 6b takes a6 is inserted um it's not
not a difference in this game okay so I
guess I'll develop the kingside first
yeah Bishop d3 castles Bishop g2 no
bishop h3 is playing interesting okay
so at least I cannot take on a six with
the bishop okay well this is probably
right um castles okay well there is six
pawn
I don't need to take it very soon and
this will be regained anyway so I'm I'm
not sure maybe Bishop e3 is more like a
preparation for 195 army not not really
sure what this is all about okay I'll
just continue with normal development
one thing could be if he goes Knight c3
I probably would have liked to take with
the bishop to kappa-b fire so that night
b5 is not a move but it's not really a
big problem is it hmm
yeah one one thing is that white might
be able to play Eve for breaking up the
center mm yeah this could be an issue
and this might be five business but this
I don't really mind so much night b5 mm
okay I wonder if I can play Queen e8 to
h5 getting the Queen involved but Queen
e8 maybe hmm maybe if form
hmm not sure yeah Queenie ate leaves the
bishop on d6 unprotected
hmm maybe still Queen yet if he goes
before I probably can play d4 hmm
yeah it's not so easy to play I mean I'm
playing all those openings that I don't
know in much detail and this type of
position here really requires to to be
precise and it's not like you can afford
slide slide in accuracy if you play
something badly here i mean you will
probably get wiped out quickly
so it's not so no it's not so easy for
me to to play this position it's not
like in the Slav or anything where you
have structures that you see every day
even in if openings like that you
regularly see top-level games and get
some kind of idea what moves are a
normal or what maneuvers are being
played and in such an uncommon position
it's always feels a bit like reinventing
the wheel all the time mark Emily
yeah Queenie aid also prepares Bishop a6
possibly as it protects ecigs yeah I'm
not so sure about concrete measures like
if for him this could be could be an
interesting tribe if for d4 Knight b5
there is d6 hanging I can take a four
but this looks totally shaky I probably
have to lose some material don't believe
in that move at all efore d4 Knight d5 I
actually thought I could maybe just
retreat to b8 intending to take Bishop
takes a6 next
yeah very complicated position all kinds
of things are possible here for white as
well I don't think the immediate night
p5 is any good then Bishop e8 really
should be just fine
hmm yeah not sure what itwhat to know
what you can do okay he said he's going
for that yeah okay so but what's the
what's the point
okay I need to move it covering it
giving up the bishop sister's useless so
to be a hm what is the big idea it just
feels like after the further Bishop
takes a six that white needs to return
and he hasn't really gained anything
Bishop f4 maybe but still Bishop a6 I
don't I don't see the the big IDM c5 is
unprotected so he could try Quincy to I
was thinking but that's probably not
really great
besides taking on a six after Quincy -
I'll also have moves like mc5 to see
form I don't understand that beehive
really maybe I'm missing a tactical idea
or some some technical as maybe the
wrong expression some something
happening a quite directly other than
that not b5 does not really do anything
great visual basics will win the tempo
on the night and it probably needs to
retreat okay yeah this is one of those
direct ideas but okay I will I will
obviously take it and what is the great
thing don't get it really I mean he can
take here but I'm not sure that all that
if that has given him all that much okay
question is how to recapture you know
Bishop takes a like rook takes actually
may be helpful to have rook a to f7
later
okay yeah now it gets very very concrete
should I start to push now queen h5 and
and stuff queen h5 Bishop g2 5 this is
possible
a possible continuation a 5 and a form
yeah come on let's not waste any time
here and now e5 intending fo i am ii 5
Bishop g5 e 4 that's just good for black
if 5 what is this response maybe Eve
form but then there are many good moves
Bishop g4 for example okay this just
looks like the right move
okay if he goes Bishop b2 now which I'm
not sure if he will do that it this is
this is a kind of move that it's not
helping right at all really we should be
- it sort of developed the piece but I
have many good good answers Bishop g4 is
one of them probably probably or after
Bishop b2 we're also have a move like d4
simply blunting this bishop and then
Bishop g4 or a form the Alice's sir
quite a serious compensation unless I'm
directly overlooking something
yeah efore has a move that would come to
mind but I can I can claim I can't even
take it with the pawn and then play
Bishop default it should be it should be
alright and I really think I'm you know
maybe relatively speaking this was the
best move but the question is what now
can I try to refute all this directly
with Bishop h3 Bishop h3 if it takes on
h3 Queen tank sage 395 Bishop II however
should be fired tonight reform and he
can take on d5 with the check that's not
not ideal there is this D form was
mentioned which is not bad
d4 might play Queen c2 after that taking
c5
yeah Bishop a3 is also very interesting
just going for it directly at the moment
I don't see any drawback with this move
Bishop h3
mmm if it takes Queen tags there should
be 594 25 check King h8 not sure could
be excellent
the thing is I'm sort of asking myself
well what exactly is he doing if I play
move like before and just stop or come
out to play against d5 and then play as
mentioned before nightfall this kind of
things isn't this just excellent anyway
Bishop a 3m I'm not quite sure
technically this come on I'm doing that
it's it's just it's just good I think
and easier to play just a practical
decision not spending more time in
figuring out of Bishop Atreus it's much
better yeah yeah here I have no chief
form at least Knight g4 with h3 and then
there are various interesting sacrifices
or Bishop h3 yeah Bishop h3 is the is
the more dangerous looking actually
just just just a moment just a moment if
I go Knight g4 there is h3 probably
coming
now I can take and sacrifice on f2 this
is very likely to work it's a very
dangerous very dangerous sacrifice hmm
interesting
now go Bishop to h3 there is from the f3
other than f95 righty I 95 Knight g4
hmm not 100% sure but I need to play
this f3 this seems to be the the only
triad a defense to me other than that
I'm playing Knight g4 and his exploding
on h2 I don't I don't see another movie
so f3 and what then I thought that e4 is
also very interesting after that because
it opens up the b8 bishop I've got every
all pieces are in the attack it would be
very strange of this this wouldn't be a
this shouldn't be great f 3e for yeah
this is for this looks very strong
actually 495 is also interesting but
he's got Knight see form covering e3
yeah what else is there Bishop f3 yep
I've got Knight g4 I cannot cannot
believe that this is just so much so
much in that tech
yeah f3 and then probably form
f 3e for probably 94 94 fe for rock Hof
7 Wow really
I know this is not going to go into hold
and eforea threatening bishop g3 yeah no
no use in spending more time rook F
Tudors III which is very important of
course okay takes and Bishop g3 okay his
may be intending he's probably intending
to after Bishop g3 to take here and
click win f1 okay okay so maybe
takes takes rook hf7 first
okay but then I cannot easily sacrifice
now that's not totally easy
I also have 95 of course
hmm amazing Bishop g3 he can take on f8
and play queen f1 very lucky that White
has this defense so okay so what am I
going to do
taking it's not good and Bishop d3 it's
not at all working it's not just in
theory it's not working at all so rook
here now threatening to take you but he
can maybe in exchange now and play Queen
d3 something like that well it still
looks very dangerous but it's maybe not
a direct win bishop this is Queen C four
checkers also also in the position okay
yeah h4 h H
H 5 H 4 is the the most obvious way to
to play aged 5 mm and I really don't I
really don't see what is doing against
this
you five I can just take it it's it's
good that she does not have any
disturbing check here Quincy four or
something and h4 is really a it's really
coming with the big impact
well maybe I had something more
convincing even but I don't see a
defense here really don't
now I don't see a defense he cannot use
the rook in any way and h4 is the next
move
it cannot capture because of Bishop h2
leading to med or a queen h2 is also
made some h4 is really really serious
and the bishop on c1 is not doing
anything he can try our Bishop c1 Dez
made on f1 so he cannot get the bishop
to f4 now I really don't see a move to
be honest maybe e5 e 5h 4y 6 but if I
can maybe just take maybe
yeah but then maybe Queenie form
Queenie for to g2
hmm which u5 I can you know that slits
one of the better tries age 4 is 6
for you six if you have move the rook
after that this is seven
okay let's consider if I take this
queenie for bishop g3 this is a winning
right bishop g3 only has one check here
takes Queen takes King hmm not sure if
it is a really winning so what about h4
again H 4 is 6 I can take with the Queen
how I then look everyone
age 46 okay
little time what what is happening here
Queen Eve form the shook g3 maybe this
is just a draw Queenie for Bishop g3
what is this doing i have h1 now come on
let's play it yeah but I can take here
first
rook f7 is not working and no hmm time
wanna take here first
look f7 there's no meat right I don't I
don't see me check yeah that's
unfortunate really check check yeah
that's very nice but the time I had 45
seconds it's not it's not it's not so
low that it's totally impossible to do
I want to get it to e3 and this is not
much time to think
anyway check here I can I can chat egg
b3
check check check
check-check
check
got this dangerous pawn jack
25 in 23 seconds check
taking c4f queen of to trick as probably
any generate check check check
check
check-check
12 seconds hmm you know I had to give up
the see porn which was unfortunate
really but okay hmm no I'm getting
getting a very quick win check checkmate
well always right right with little time
on the clock
yeah it fits like it should have been
over before that but I didn't find a
total knockout around here and two
minutes is not much let's let's check
this I'd really like to like to see
what's going on here let's let's start
around here I mean keep it within within
reason so the computer actually gives us
a zero zero zero interesting what is the
issue okay hmm yeah yeah yeah the
computer is of obviously in such a
concrete position it's very strong here
points out that this movies is winning
instantly and the idea is if always if
it's the right idea but he just computer
just prepares this and there is no way
for whites to do anything about it
yeah efore is now hitting next move with
with even bigger effect something like I
just played without him and then there's
a foe and he cannot even take here yeah
because I can instantly smash on g3
yeah nice very nice so this this was
much stronger okay he formed this is
very logical also this and queen d3 it
seems that if I F was the right defense
here according to the computer okay oops
I'm sorry need to attend to the door
alright I'm back after answering the
door so if I Bishop e5 and now Queen d3
seems to be a defense here okay
it's somewhat better than the game I
guess h5 would transpose okay it's
interesting so this is what we had and
now h5 85 and now h4 is the right move
okay yeah I had a suspicion but I wasn't
really able to figure that out so this
is right okay
I said I simply didn't want to leave
their file but it seems just like a
concrete win here yeah yeah I'll take on
g3 yeah he cannot stop that yeah I
wasn't sure this is somewhat didn't look
right okay but I understand take on
nature on g3 next so okay I took it and
now Queenie form which she did not play
strangely enough this should have lost
instantly okay Queenie this is what I
had expected but then I would have taken
on g3 and thought okay well this is at
least a draw maybe it is a draw yeah
after this this may be nothing more he
always has this the OS has this defense
check which which we draw this is
probably not on check
hmm my computer gives it also as a draw
yeah it always check is this counter
play that's hurting me with the draw hmm
okay but that it didn't replayed this
one which which really looked a bit
wrong H fry played no this and now I can
take on g3 recaptures and Bishop takes
Bishop takes us winning yeah I briefly
thought about it but I didn't ah of
course just Bishop h2 I was just
thinking about this yeah I briefly
calculated this right because it just
looks funny to get the King out but here
I stopped I saw up to this and didn't
see anything after after that but I just
forgot that there is Bishop h2 we are of
course I'm just winning the Queen iam
yeah then this is of course totally
winning
ah that's stupid I'm Bishop g3 just just
resigns after that there's this mate and
absolutely nothing he can do it just
loses the Queen for nothing okay yeah
okay I went went here okay but this will
also wins oh yeah I can take and play d3
yeah yeah just promote yeah this is much
better even Jackie I went for this I
mean this is also something that should
win but chances of course much much more
work than check check what what I did of
course was checks or influenced by the
time it always should be a winner but
check I had to I could have had it could
have had a much easier life check check
yeah tons of chess iam yeah black is
winning us nothing nothing else to say
him
very interesting so this this opening is
this interesting it's always leads to
leads to sharp play it's it's probably
not the most solid around but it's it's
a good if you wonder fight yeah I don't
really know about that it didn't look
right to me
so it's AB lots of time this is this
idea funny the computer gives an a7 here
which looks totally weird I'm not able
to play something like that here and
then take with the rook then Knight g5
totally computers line yeah very tough
ok I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching